Oh hey, Critic!
Merry Christmas Eve--
What's so merry about it?!
I have just seen the absolute worst
Holiday special of all time!
Santa Zombie Eats Jesus?
Worse!
It's so bad I haven't slept in nights!
It's kept me awake throughout the entire season!
If I'm not careful, I might start hallucinating!
Hey, Critic!
Who are you talking to?
You got any NyQuil?
[Nostalgia Critic theme]
Hello, I'm Nostalgia Critic.
I remember it so you don't have to!
And Merry Christmas Eve to you...
...Or at least it would be!
Before I found out this unholy abomination existed!
That's right, I have found it!
I have found the absolute worst
Christmas special of all time!
Hands down, no comparison, YULETIDE CRAP!
It's called....
The Christmas Tree.
[cheery music plays]
It's unlikely you've ever heard of it,
but it's getting more and more of a
following as, you've guessed it,
the worst Holiday Special ever made!
Its acting, atrocious!
Its animation, beyond cheap!
Its story?
What brain operated by a dead hamster on a broken spinning wheel would be fucking stupid enough to greenlight this shit?!
It might be the only Christmas special
where literally everything about it
was done completely 100 percent WRONG.
And I mean EVERYTHING!!
There are no words to describe how bad it is.
It just has to be witnessed!
And that is why you are here, isn't it?
You are interested in the unknown,
the mysterious, the unexplainable.
That is why you are here...
And now, for the first time
we are bringing to you the full story
of what happened that fateful day.
We are giving to you ALL the evidence
based ONLY on the secret testimonials of the
miserable souls who survived this terrifying ordeal!
The incidents...
The places...
My friend, we cannot keep this a secret any longer!
Let us punish the guilty!
Let us reward the innocent!
My friend...
Can your heart stand the shocking facts
about The Christmas Tree?!
[Thunder clapping]
Let's find out...
It opens with a clichéd narrator reading a clichéd book
that looks more like a dictionary of
Tetris pieces than legible literature.
Narrator: "Our story takes place in an orphanage
with some children and a pine tree."
"The orphaned children lived under the control
of the evil rules of a lady named..."
"Mrs. Mavilda."
D'AAH! Movement!!
[Narration continues]
Oh, I'm sorry. That so RARELY happens in this special.
"The children never had toys, new clothes or anything."
"But they had a friend."
"The pine tree they named Mrs. Hopewell."
"Yes, Hopewell."
"Because the kids believed that the tree was magical!"
The kids were obviously exposed to too much car exhaust to imagine such a non-imaginative idea.
"She had a pretty dress with bows and
lace and a new pair of pants and a sweater"
"to put on whichever child she
was going to show off to the mayor."
"This way, every time the mayor came by,"
"he always thought that Mrs. Mavilda
was taking good care of her children."
A thorough inspection, as you can see,
accompanied by the fact that
direct deposits and business checks
have now been replaced with... big bags of money.
Hey! Who needs a paper trail when
you have millionaire duck currency?
"Mrs. Mavilda would immediately take off the
child's clothes and put them away in a closet
for the mayor's next visit.
Poor children..."
Well, you're not making the situation better by uncomfortably holding on their naked bodies like that--
Thank you!
So, Mrs. Mavilda bets all the money she
has on poker games with her friends
and the kids continue to suffer for it.
She doesn't even let them feed
the street dog named Licorice
as she tries to have the pound take him away.
[Leash snaps]
[barking]
[Orphans cheer]
What is up with this kid?
The other children are at least clapping and cheering
but he's just rocking his head like a psychopath!
[children cheering]
Play some heavy metal music over that!
[heavy metal music plays]
I LIKE DOOOOOGS!!!
Later on, we see a family moves
into town and is looking for work.
So they go to the mayor...
... which doesn't really seem like his jurisdiction
but again, he keeps his bank account in money bags.
And he tells them that the husband can work at the lumber mill but has to live in the boarding house without his family.
However, he offers the family a
chance to live at "Chateau De Fuckhole"
where Mrs. Mavilda will take the
mother, named Judy, in as an assistant.
"We've come from the mayor's."
"I know, I know!"
[dully] "I better go now.
Take good care of yourself and the children, Judy.
I will be back before Christmas."
Wow!
David Duchovny on quaaludes
could show more emotion than that!
"Goodbye, children. Be good."
Nostalgia Critic: "I'm gonna check with the
doctor and see if I'm clinically still alive."
"Can we go now?"
So Mrs. Mavilda explains that
Judy's kids have to be treated the
exact same way as the other kids.
"They're going to stay with the other children
and under the same rules and regulations."
"I'm sorry."
"Come children,
follow me--
Another thing,
you have to..."
The hell was that?!
"Come children, follow me--
Another thing,"
"I apologize, sometimes my other
personality interrupts me--"
"No, I don't--"
"SHUT UP, WHORE!"
"This is going to be your bedroom."
"I don't want to hear anybody crying around here
and most of all, NO PILLOW FIGHTS!
You understand?"
"Because...
if you think that you're not going to be punished
because you have your mother here...
you're going to be MIGHTY disappointed."
Nostalgia Critic: "I'll get you,
my frozen, awkwardly blinking pretties!"
"And your repeated two frames of animation too!"
[witch-like cackling]
So Judy's kids try to see if they
can fit in with the other children.
[shuddering]
Was that supposed to be charming them
or satanically hypnotizing them?
[creepy music plays]
But their creepy-ass smiles seem to win them
over and they start to know each other better.
[garbled] "My teddy bear has only one arm,
but my mom says Santa will bring a new one for him."
... What?
"Not when you go through the window..."
"What the hell did you just say?"
Yeah... I don't know if this kid is the director's,
the producer's or even the casting agent's
but there is NO way she got through
any kind of audition process.
"Santa is busy all year!"
"Mommy, come here and see Mrs. Hopewell!"
"And besides, I brought some cheese."
She's not... technically killing the
art of human speech as we know it
but she IS the seed that'll grow a horrifyingly large oak.
Speaking of which,
the kids show Judy their only friends:
the tree named Mrs. Hopewell and their dog Licorice.
And, to the mumbling girl's credit,
none of these other kids are gonna win
anything resembling human respect
with THESE performances either.
[slurred] "I knew we should've
never shown him to your mother..."
"Adults are always the same."
"I just learned how to speak three days ago
and, according to the Craigslist posting,
that's all you need to be in this movie."
"Now we have to do something for Mrs. Hopewell too!"
"I've got an idea!"
Nostalgia Critic:
"We'll decorate her with her dead brethren!"
"That way, she'll remember that no matter how pretty she is, she'll always be thought of as a tool,
much like you children are in this movie!"
So the mayor sees the kids and Judy getting along
and thinks that they deserve even more money.
"This year, I've collected more
money for the children's Christmas.
I've got enough money here to
get the children new clothes.
... And still some left for their..."
Did he just have a Vietnam flashback for a second?
"I've got enough money here to
get the children new clothes."
[Gunshot and yelling]
"...And still some left for their Christmas presents."
"Here you go, Mrs. Mavilda. Here's the two bags."
My god! He didn't even give the
amount; he just said "two bags"!
I don't even think he measures
the money in terms of numbers.
I think he literally measures it in BAG SIZE!
Mr. Mayor, this check says it's for...
two money bags?
That's right, two whole money bags!
Mr. Mayor, I'm gonna need an
exact amount in order to accept--
I USE MONEY BAGS!!
Okay...
We'll take the money bags!
Very good! Now if you'll excuse me,
my ride is waiting for me.
[Car honking]
"I'm glad those poor little things aren't going to
have to spend another winter in patches and rags."
"By the way, where is Judy?"
"Oh! Mrs. Kindell!"
D'AAH!
"Good that you're here."
"I just gave Mrs. Mavilda--"
That was awfully quick, I didn't even hear a footstep!
What, did she just beam herself into the room?
"By the way, where is Judy?"
[Teleportation sound]
"Oh! Mrs. Kindell!
Good that you're here."
So the mayor wants her to pick out fancy new clothes
for the children as Christmas gifts.
But the kids don't know what Christmas is.
So Judy explains.
"Christmas is a pretty and happy time of the year."
"A time when people get together.
Friends with friends,
Children with their parents and grandparents..."
D'uuuhhhh...
Ixnay the arents-pay...
Orphans...ay...
"Santa Claus is everybody's grandpa."
"And how can his sleigh fly?"
"Cause he has special reindeer to pull it and
each one...has its own special name."
Okay...
What's this kid drinking?
She's slurring more than an inebriated Klansman!
"I wish my little teddy bear
had his other arm."
So she tells them that on Christmas
they can all make a simple wish.
No, not that one! But it would explain a lot...
So we get a scene of all the kids
wishing for happy things to occur.
But strangely enough, while this scene is going on,
they keep cutting back and forth
to Mrs. Mavilda's poker game...
And it's edited so awkwardly that we're usually only seeing the poker game for just a couple of seconds.
"I guess you've never seen a Christmas tree before."
What didja-- WHA?
"Let's roll, kids!"
"I'm feeling lucky tonight!"
Uh, wasn't done yet but...
Judy: "He's not anybody's grandpa."
"Mom, can I be the first one
to make a Christmas... wish?"
"Think HARD before you do."
Uh, wait, I think there was more--
"Good luck, Mavilda!"
"Let's have another hand!"
I don't think that we're done yet!
"I wish that my little teddy bear--"
Okay...
Why show these two things at the same time
if we're not going to show them for
more than a couple of seconds?!
Can we intercut other sloppily
edited scenes while we're at it?!
"Oh, maybe if there's some money left over,
I can convince Mrs. Mavilda to buy some red velvet.
That way I can make some Christmas
stockings to hang on the fireplace."
"Red velvet? For stockings?"
"What's that?"
"Don't you know about Christmas stockings
that you hang on the fireplace for Santa Claus to fill?"
"You don't!?"
"Which one of you knows about Christmas?"
"I do!"
"Christmas...
Christmas...Well, let me tell you about it."
So it turns out Mrs. Mavilda
bet ALL the money and lost it.
Meaning she can't get any new clothes.
"I want to tell you something and you better listen!"
"I don't want the children playing outside anymore."
"You better make sure out that!!"
"Because you don't want the mayor
to see them without new clothes!"
"How can you dare to..."
"ALL RIGHT!!"
"Now you know..."
"And now that you know, you better
make sure you don't tell him a thing!"
"Or you and your children are out in the cold."
[giggles maniacally]
"Now you go get those children back inside!"
"Before my brain gets taken
over by another personality!"
[giggles then stops]
So, Judy lets the kids know the bad news.
"You know the new clothes we promised you?"
"Well, I'm afraid..."
"you're not going to be getting them."
"Oh no..."
"I know, I know. But there's nothing I can do about it."
"That's not fair, Mrs. Kindell!"
"Please, children, don't make it more difficult for me."
Nostalgia Critic: "I mean, Jesus,
all you kids ever do is think about yourselves!"
"Don't you kids ever think about ME
thinking about you thinking about yourselves?!"
But Mrs. Mavilda decides that Judy is
getting too much respect from the kids.
So she tries to figure out a way to get rid of her.
"She's changing everything around here..."
"I got to get rid of her..."
"But how?!"
Well, maybe you can start by
getting out off the fuckin bed.
It's like 1 o'clock, you lazy bitch! Get movin'!
"What if I make that good girl into a bad one?"
[giggles maniacally]
"Yeah!"
"I'll make her into a thief!"
"Just like I did with the girl that worked with me before."
Wh--di--w--When was that?!
We never saw that!
Okay, is this, like, a real person
or are we to assume this is yet ANOTHER
personality that she has in her head?!
This woman's making A Beautiful Mind
look like a simple romp!
So she calls her henchman...
Yeah, she has a henchman,
[Brooklyn accent] what with the accents and stuffs,
And asks him to frame Judy
for stealing something of his.
But one of the girls hears her and tells the other kids.
They all decide to that something has to be done.
"We can't just stay here without doing something!"
"What can we do?"
[high-pitched] "What about your mother?
She's also in danger!"
The hell is that?!
"--the only one who knows where his office is."
"Do you know where his house is?"
Okay...Zortor. Your impression of a
small human child isn't fooling anybody.
Curses! I'll get you next time, pitifully dubbed humans!
[shrill evil laughter]
Speaking of which, there's a great irony that all of these children are obviously voiced by horrible child actors
But one girl is clearly voiced by an 18-year-old!
"You mean you don't think our
star is gonna make it on time?"
"What if one of us goes to him?"
"But where are we and where is his house?"
Okay, pick one.
Either horrible adult actors, horrible child actors or aliens trying to pose as children to take over the universe!
[shrill maniacal laughter]
So the children decide that
Judy's kids should go and get help.
From who you may ask?
Santa Clause, of course!
Yeah...why not?
"Look, here in my book!
It shows that we're not far from his house!"
Wha...the...
What decapitated gingerbread cookie do they live on?!
Even Mario would be looking at this saying:
"Whoa, that's a fucked up-ah kingdom!"
"I don't know where the North Pole is...do you?"
"I don't."
"I don't"
[yelping bark]
"He knows where the North Pole is!"
"He does?"
Well, he barked. Obviously, that translates
into knowing where the North Pole is.
Quite a knowledgeable little scamp isn't he?
Say, I wonder what else he knows about?
Hey, Licorice! Do you know
if we're alone in the universe?
[barks]
Wow! Do you know why smart
people keep watching The Middle?
[barks]
Wow! Do you know who really killed JFK?
My God! The answers were right there!
I have to go to the police about this!
The world must know, damn it!
THE WORLD MUST KNOW--!
I'll be right back.
[gunshots]
"What? Another commercial?"
Well, this one's really quick.
I just wanted to tell you that at TheAwesomeStore.com, we are extending our sale on our DVDs
and also our charity drive pictures.
So, that is going to be going until the first of next year.
So you can still get the good prices on that,
also, our metal prints are in and they're
being shipped out even as we speak.
If there's any more left, you can take a look,
see if you can order some more.
And...that's about it. Back to the show!
Oh, also uh... you will die if you don't know this--.
So, Judy's kids go with Licorice to find the North Pole.
"Don't be mad, Pappy. I just had to come."
Uh, she's down there, kid.
You're staring at nothing right now.
Please look down. Please look down. Please look d--
There ya go!
But they come across some troubles on their search,
like Baloo from the Jungle Book!
[screaming]
[loud roaring]
Nostalgia Critic: [demonic voice]
"Bare necessities! Your asses are my recipes!"
"The simple bare necessities of DEATH!"
[growling]
[roaring]
Jesus, they couldn't even make it a polar bear!
Even Santa Clause Conquers the Martians
got that one right!
[dull] "Help me, Pappy! Help me!"
***damnit, you're hanging on for dear life!
Show some fucking emotion ya little twat!
[bear roaring]
"PAPPY!"
Nostalgia Critic: "Even in death, I don't care..."
[growling]
Nostalgia Critic: "In hindsight, I am a pretty dumb bear."
[loud thud]
Pappy: "Lily!"
[voice echoing] "Lily!"
"Lily!"
"Where are you? Where'd you go?"
Oh, Jesus, kid! Will somebody just try?!
SOMEBODY?
GOD! I'll juggle porcupines with my buttcheeks if I could just get one production assistant or a cast member
or the director or SOMEBODY just to say:
"Maybe, fucking maybe, we should do that take again!!"
JESUS H. JESUS!
Can we just get somebody
with some ***damn emotion!?
Mrs. Mavilda: [yelling] "GET OUT!
Pack your things right now!!"
"You're fired!"
CHRIST!
Spastic hyenas aren't as loud as you!
"You're fired!"
You're blowing out the volume levels! I don't think
the microphone have an Insane Bitch setting on it...
...except maybe in her case.
"Frank?"
"Do you still have that electric chainsaw of yours?"
So, Mrs. Mavilda calls her henchman to cut
down the tree-- Oh, sorry, "Mrs. Hopewell".
They've established such a strong presence
with her, I'm SURPRISED I forgot,
as the kids go out and try to stop them.
"Nobody cuts Mrs. Hopewell until we talk to the Mayor!"
"Show them the saw!"
"Whatever you say, Ma'am."
[chainsaw roaring]
Mayor: "What is the meaning of this?!"
Nostalgia Critic:
"Wasn't there snow here just a moment ago?"
"Turn that thing off! I can't hear a thing!"
[barking]
Pappy: "Mommy! Mommy!"
"But, where's Lily? Where is she?"
"She's gone, Mommy..."
"Oh, god! What do you mean?!"
"Ray..."
[stuttering] WHERE'D HE COME FROM??
Nostalgia Critic:
[imitates Ray]"I randomly materialized here just in time."
"Tell me, son. What happened to Lily?"
"She fell from a cliff Mommy, Daddy... all the way down."
[chuckles] Yeah, cuz that's my reaction
if I just found out my little kid died!
So, while the Mayor is there, he finds out all the
terrible things that Mrs. Mavilda has been doing.
"What happened with the money that I've been donating? Why didn't Mavilda buy toys for them?"
"And look at them!
They look like they haven't had new clothes in years!"
"What if the Inspector were to come?!"
[snickers] I love how he doesn't care that the
children's well-being has been put in horrible danger,
But instead is more concerned if the
Inspector sees him and calls him out on it!
"What if the Inspector were to come?!"
"Voters don't like their politicians
connected to dead children."
"Uh...they are still alive, right?"
"Your tree--I mean, Mrs. Hopewell
is going to be all right."
Okay, is the mayor slowly transforming
into an Adam Sandler voice?
Because Sandler already ruined one holiday and I don't think this movie needs any help ruining this one!
[chainsaw roaring]
"That's what you think, children!"
But Mrs. Mavilda grabs the chainsaw
and is about to finish the job.
Children: "OH NO!"
[lighting crackling]
[thunder clapping]
Mrs. Mavilda: [screams]
HOLY SHIT!
The moral of the story is
"Don't fuck with Mrs. Hopewell!"
[demonic voice] "I am the bark of Satan!"
"Those who wish to demean my
evil will be bloodily smoted!"
[bells jingling]
Santa Clause:
"Ho, ho, ho! Merry Christmas, everybody!"
Ah, so it was Santa who fried
the flesh of a weak, feeble woman.
Merry...Christmas...?
[popping sound]
Um...I think those lights are supposed to actually be
ON the tree and not a little to the left of the tree...
but, I guess it's the thought that counts.
And clearly, none of that went into this at all.
"Mommy!"
"Oh, Lily! I'm so glad to see you!"
"I missed all of you, Mommy!"
[shudders]
And the distrubing Santa Coke ad agrees...
"Look! Santa's leaving!"
Santa: "Peace be with you all!"
Nostalgia Critic: "What's this shit on my shoulder?
Oh! I guess it does that, okay!"
Santa: "Have a merry Christmas and a happy New Year!"
Yeah, creepy-voice Santa has no time for
individually visiting houses anymore,
he just sort of air-bombs gifts now
in the hopes that whoever picks it up in
the morning will like it or some crap.
So, everything seems to end happily.
Look, even Mrs. Mavilda somehow
got out without a scratch on her.
How the flying fuck do you do that!?
Narrator: "And Mrs. Mavilda...well...
Mrs. Mavilda, she's going to be all right."
"From what I've heard, she went back to work
in the orphanage as Judy's assistant!"
[laughs light-heartedly]
Nostalgia Critic: "True, that lightning fucked with her head and she constantly pisses her pants and calls herself "The Chicken God"
"But aside from that, she's gonna be all right!"
Narrator: "Well, don't worry about Mrs. Mavilda."
"She's good now. She learned that
you always win when you are good."
"Merry Christmas, everybody!"
Oh, and I suppose that's your half-assed
little message at the end right?
Mmhmm, yeah, no, no, it's good, it's really good, I like it, you did a good job, you did good, good job, Special,
I-I love this, only 45 minutes, it felt like an eternity but, you know, you did good, I just so love it, everything.
all the characters and everything about it was so good, I just love it, you did so good, I just love it,
you did so good,
[incoherent sqeaking]
FUCK YOOOOUUU!!!!
Do I even need to say what's wrong with it? Not really.
It's pretty obvious. Horrible acting, horrible writing, horrible directing and horrible animation.
But, here's the thing. A lot of people are saying
this is the animated equivalent of The Room.
One of those films that's so hypnotizingly
bad that it's actually good.
And...in some respects...they're actually kind of right.
This can be very entertaining
to laugh at and make fun of.
Everything is so awkward and strange that
you can't help but burst out into hilarity.
But the problem is, it's a Christmas movie.
CHRISTMAS. Really think about that.
This is the season where even the worst Holiday Specials at least TRY to give something
either entertaining or heartfelt because they feel
they owe it to such a beautiful time of year.
And, what does this film end up giving us?
"You always win when you are good."
Yeah, this is the holiday where charities all over the world go up and people give more than ever to those
who have so little and expect nothing in return.
They do it because they know it's right and this is
the time to celebrate what's good in the world.
And...what does this film end up giving us?
"You always win when you are good."
This is the time of year that brought a WAR to a halt!
Because the message of good
will toward men was so strong.
Because it was a symbol to stop hatred, stop killing, stop everything spreading anything that didn't equal love and respect for everyone in the world.
This is a holiday that is THAT powerful.
So, just to reiterate, you Christmas Special that
clearly understands the holiday you're representing,
What then, is the meaning of Christmas?
"You always win when you are good."
Cuz, that's what Christmas is, THAT'S what Christmas is! You got it, Special! You fucking got it!
No! NO YOU DIDN'T!
And that's why this is the worst Special!
I'll tell you why, because Christmas is not about that,
it's not about that dumbass little message
it was trying to throw in at the last minute.
You know what? It's not even really about giving
or sharing or love or anything about that,
that's a part of it,
but there's something even more important!
You want to know what it is?
I'll tell you what Christmas is!
Christmas is EFFORT!
It's putting effort into that kindness, it's putting effort into that sharing, it's putting effort into that loving
cuz, anyone can just give something,
anyone can just BUY something,
whether it costs a million bucks if you're rich or nothing if you're poor, but by God, it's the effort you put into it!
If you got something someone really wanted,
then that's effort.
Or if you made something that somebody
didn't even know they wanted, that's effort!
That's loving! It's putting the effort into that stuff! And that is something that is clearly not in this special!
They just slapped it together, didn't give a shit,
and you can't do that on Christmas man!
You have to try! You have to try to make this stuff good because that is what we are trying to do!
It's about putting effort in something
that is even bigger than yourself
cuz, when somebody comes up to me and wishes me a holiday from a religion maybe I don't celebrate,
if somebody said "Happy Haqnnuhka" to
me, I'd wish them "Merry Christmas" back.
You know, what? We'd be fine with it.
You wanna know why? Because we're both sharing something that we believe is bigger than ourselves!
That is putting effort into that. That is celebrating something that's wonderful and loving and unbelievable.
It's putting that effort into Christmas.
Into sharing something so great and fantastic!
[sighs]
Let me show you something,
follow me Mr. Camera Man, follow me!
You know, it is all about effort, cuz
that is the what we're trying to do here.
We're trying to all come together
so that we can celebrate
and put that effort into everything
that is good with the world!
Like these people right here!
Look at how much effort these
people put in all the time!
Unbelievable! Come here, come here, you guys!
These are people that work behind the scenes, in front of the scenes also, they do such a good job!
Guys. [sighs] You've been doing so great.
You got the "That Guy With the Glasses"
audience watching right now.
Is there anything you would like
to say to them this Christmas Eve?
[British accent] God bless us, everyone.
[giggles]
Marry Christmas, Mr. Potter.
How about you, you got a movie quote?
Uh...
Not really. But as we approach the new year, just know that always want to get better and don't get drunk.
[snickers]
See, that's effort.
Whether it be a movie quote that means a lot to them
or, you know, something very sincere, that's effort!
I love you guys! You guys are awesome!
But it doesn't stop there because we keep going out here
showing more of the effort, more of the...
It's about THIS guy!
Christmas is about this guy right here, that's right.
The Camera Man, my brother Rob.
He's been working so hard.
Hey, hey hey! No, no no! Stand up, stand up, come on!
You've been working so hard, you've
got everybody watching you right now.
Anything you want to wish people this Christmas?
Uh...
Merry Christmas...?
Oh, come on! You do better than that, come on!
And a happy new year...
Come on! Bigger than that!
...You filthy animal.
Oh, for God's sake, you can't think of
anything better to say on Christmas Eve!?
Okay, fine. It's...
You know, it's a little hard to get into the Christmas spirit
with the way it's been...over-commercialized and stuff
but, really when you think deep about it,
Christmas is not just a bunch of things that you buy.
[stammering] It's about an attitude, a spirit.
Something you carry with you in your heart!
When 2000 years ago a man was born into a stable,
not adorned with gifts and presents and stuff and trees.
But born into poverty and you see that every day.
When a child does something nice for his grandma.
Or, when, you know, we give things
to homeless people, you know.
It's something that-that lasts, that endures and
goes on and on though the mountains may fall
and the hills turn to dust!
Okay, okay, okay! Take the camera, take the camera.
Okay, okay. Here. Out here.
Out here, out here, out here! Okay, okay!
It's about believing in something
bigger than yourself, like I said.
And putting that effort into it. Because you don't have to believe in Christianity or Catholicism or any of that stuff.
You don't have to be in a religion. You just have to believe in humanity and that's what's so great about it!
It's believing in the best of humanity and
the effort that's put into that bestness!
It's about...these two.
This is my mom and dad.
They put so much effort into raising me.
Because they are so awesome that way.
This guy joined the Navy so he
could help support and raise us,
and my mom...
she was going to be an opera singer!
But she had two kids and said "You know what?
I'm gonna spend my life dedicated to that."
And that is so unbelievable and that is Christmas!
That is such goodness!
There's such goodness in these people.
So, Dad, you got so many people watching right now.
Is there anything you want to say to the "That Guy
with the Glasses" audience on Christmas Eve here?
Merry Christmas to all of you.
And most importantly, remember...
We have lots of merchandise in
the Channel Awesome country store!
15% off if your name rhymes with Walker!
-Nice, nice, nice!
It's gonna be really--yeah, yeah, okay.
That's the kind of ham he is!
That's the kind of guy that my dad is and you
can see where I got my terrible sense of humor.
But nonetheless, he has spent--
[stammering] Come on.
But nonetheless, he has worked so hard to raise us and he has just been so positive, so upbeat,
and I love my dad.
And mom...I got a question for you, it's a question I
really wanted to save for you because your so loving
and your so heartfelt and everything.
There's a lot of people out there who don't
associate Christmas with the best stuff.
Maybe they don't have any friends or
much family and maybe their spending it alone
or maybe they associate it with a bad time, there's
so many bad things that happen out there
and Christmas is such a good time!
I know you feel it, you feel it like I feel it.
What can you say to people out there who
are not having such a good Christmas?
Uh, you know, this is the time of year to reach out to someone else who is lonely or is having a hard time.
And do something nice for them, because when you do that, you'll feel less lonely inside of yourself as well.
It's the perfect time of year to do something
for somebody else and think of others.
That's really nice, mom. Thanks so much.
This movie sucks balls...but I love YOU.
Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas!
-Merry Christmas.
[soft music fades]
[Nostalgia Critic Theme plays]
Thanks so much, guys. Merry Christmas to ya.
[chuckles]
Who the hell was that?
[mouthing] I don't know.
Mrs. Mavilda: [shouting] YOU'RE FIRED!